one two
five rockets fired into the sea Target
a decommissioned Philippine Navy vessel
22 kilometers from where a U.S High Mars
launched the missiles
arid Naval assets reinforced ground
artillery
the ship's sinking exercise was the
first for the annual War Games known as
balikatan which means shoulder to
shoulder and the Philippine president
himself Ferdinand Marcos Jr was there to
witness history the president watched
the exercise and he understands the
challenges that is entailed in doing a
combined operation at this level and
from that the appreciation of the
president is what we came out with
the mark enemy ship was anchored in
Waters close to the south of China Sea
where Manila and Beijing have competing
claims but officials say the sinking
exercise wasn't directed to China
the message is not geared toward
anything outside of
the strong relationship and bond with
the Philippines
Beijing had earlier warned that
increased defense cooperation between
Manila and its allies should not
interfere in Maritime disputes
this year's palikatan joined drills
between the Philippines and the United
States aren't just the biggest with
around 17 600 troops participating
they're also taking place amid
heightened tensions over Taiwan and the
territorial disputes in the South China
Sea
adding to the unrest Marcus granting U.S
forces access to four more military
bases in addition to five approved under
the enhanced defense cooperation
agreement signed in 2014. three of them
are near Taiwan besides the numbers
conceptualized
2022 so it was only expected now but
with how it's being conducted now with
respect to other developments
particularly our foreign policy posture
is being the shape under current
Administration under President
after more than six hours of coordinated
hits guided bombs dropped by a U.S
marine fighter jet sank the ship
victory in a simulated battle
one both armies hope will never become a
reality
partner below Al Jazeera zambales the
Philippines